hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast introducing an ancestral
a diverse whole genome data set for
select cohort and control research
applications presented by benjamin d
solomon md we're excited to bring this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by triage and
bioinformatics cryogen offers a targeted
product portfolio that enables insight
some samples for virtually any
application involving DNA and RNA the
building blocks of life cryogen has
partnered with the anova Translational
Medicine Institute to offer a collection
of high-quality annotated whole genome
sequences for diverse clinical
applications to learn more about cryogen
bioinformatics please visit www for
maddox com I am Judy O'Rourke of levers
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen Lancers many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you'll be viewing the presentation
in the slide window to enlarge the
window just click on the screen icon
located on the right side and finally if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. Benjamin d seulement chief
of the division of medical genomics at
the innova Translational Medicine
Institute dr. Sullivan is an
accomplished scientist and medical
geneticist who is dual board certified
in pediatrics and clinical genetics
through the National Human Genome
Research Institute is previously held
positions at the National Institutes of
Health researching the genetic and
genomic causes of both rare and common
conditions especially certain types of
congenital anomalies at the innova
Translational Medicine Institute
Roman meets the medical genomics
division a group of clinicians and
researchers that focuses on providing
genetic and genomic medical care
discovering new explanations for genetic
disorders and studying the best ways to
integrate cutting-edge genomic resources
into clinical practice today you will be
speaking about groundbreaking studies
that have generated a data set of nearly
7,000 fully sequenced genomes annotated
with familial relationship ancestral
origin and clinical phenotypes that have
been the focus of a number of recent
publications please join me in welcoming
dr. Solomon I will now turn the
presentation over here thanks very much
for the kind introduction I trust that
folks out there will let me know if
they're having trouble hearing me or if
the connections not good excuse me if
I'm going to go ahead and dive right
into the presentation again I'm very
grateful for the opportunities to
present what we're doing and what we
hope to do and how we partnered with
kyochon and ingenuity for some of these
projects I way of disclosures I want to
mention one thing I grew up for most of
my childhood in New York so perhaps the
consequence I tend to talk very fast
especially when I start to talk about
something I'm excited about such as
genetics and genomics and the clinical
applications so also ask that if there
if i'm speaking too quick for human
intelligibility please someone shout out
or send me a message so i can slow down
a little bit and with that i'm going to
go ahead and dive right in the talk is
kind of loosely organized into three
overlapping sections first i'm going to
talk about background about who we are
and what our studies entail then the
types of data that we're generating
second doll describe examples of some of
the cases that we focus on and I've
chosen intentionally some of the
Mendelian type or perhaps an of one type
of analyses though I'm not going to go
into these in the talk we separately do
a lot of work on complex type diseases
such as
preterm birth and other conditions that
are multifactorial and if souks have
questions about some of the non and of
one some of the more sophisticated and
long-term analyses that we do I
encourage them to contact me or discuss
them further if any questions ideas for
collaborations or other input arises and
then finally if you'll indulge me at the
end I'm going to talk a little bit about
some of the lessons I've learned through
being involved in this relatively large
scale genomic project here and as well
as through some of my previous work at
the NIH and how I think that's affecting
health care systems like ours and the
health care systems more generally as
well as society is for any of us that
are practicing anything that really
touches genomic excuse me so to start
with I'm going to go into some
background information so many of you
may have not heard of a nova previous to
this we're a relatively help large
healthcare system as you can see from
the map there were located in northern
virginia around the washington DC region
and we have six main hospitals this
includes a independent women in
children's hospital and obviously that
goes along with that a relatively large
ambulatory health care system network
and we serve as you can see a lot of
patients about 2 million patient visits
a year and we're especially strong in
deliveries so we have about 20,000
deliveries system-wide for a year of
infants about half of those occur at our
main campus where our research institute
is located and our main campus is a
complex of different different hospital
units again includes a large Children's
Hospital and we do a lot of deliveries
here our research institute was started
about five or six years ago depending on
how you do the map it was started by dr.
John near Huber who is the former head
of the National Cancer Institute so when
his presidential appointment as the head
of the NCI ended he came on to be the
CEO of the innova Translational Medicine
Institute and we have all sorts of fancy
descriptions
and details about what we do but it
really boils down to doing relatively
large scale research on genomics
figuring out how we can use genomics
correlated with other biological
information and clinical data to make
new discoveries about human health and
disease and perhaps just as challenging
Lee or maybe even more challenging Lee
how do we take that information and use
it in a busy active healthcare system
and we all know this is a very fast
moving target and the technologies and
the analytic techniques are changing
very quickly regulation often as a hard
time keeping track of how quick things
are changing so this is a big and
challenging problem with one that needs
a lot of expertise to address our
staffing we have approximately 90 to 100
folks now not counting all the large
collaborations we have is roughly a
third clinical a third IT informatics
classic diaphragmatic and about a third
lab and we do both clinical care as well
as a lot of research based applications
and these span things from the lab to
the bed size and back and forth I do
want to mention briefly that ANOVA very
recently purchased and actually just
about a month and a half ago got the
keys to this complex that you're seeing
now this was the former headquarters of
X and mobile-based its move to Texas
this is been bought and is being real
fitted as the anova center for
personalized health which will be
dedicated in large part to the practice
of personalized or precision medicine
and especially genomics that picture at
the top is are the governor of the
Commonwealth Virginia Terry McAuliffe at
the announcement and you can see the man
smiling up at him happily that's the CEO
who's actually who is obviously very
excited that we're able to take
possession of this property and again
this is about a 1.2 million-square-foot
complex and all around there which is
not typical for the Washington DC
metropolitan area is a lot of unused
land and we plan to additionally build
other buildings that will also be
dedicated to personalize in precision
this and so we're all very excited about
the fact that our health care system has
really put its money where its mouth is
in terms of the practice of this type of
clinical care I'm going to start going
into some of the details about our
studies now so our studies revolve
around a number of themes they involve
trio based whole genome sequencing
meaning we always get sequence from mom
dad and baby I in a significant
proportion we also get sequence and
participation from other family members
such as aunts and uncles grandparents
other siblings and so on we generate as
much other omics and samples allow at
the RNA epigenetic protein and other
levels some of it general some of it
directed at specific hypotheses
especially of folks that are affected
with certain conditions we attempt to
collect tissue for example a baby with a
cardiac anomaly that's getting cardiac
surgery we try to get tissue that's
being discarded after the surgery to
have as part of our biorepository to do
functional analyses on validation
studies and so on we collect clinical
data from our electronic healthcare
records system ethics we also supplement
the electronic health care record based
data with study specific surveys that we
send out regularly to our participants
and we bring everything together into a
unified database to increase statistical
power regardless of the specific
question being asked I'll go into some
of what these studies are but we have a
couple of relatively large studies and
then as you can see on the right rich
says diseases a number of smaller
studies more targeting specific
conditions this gives you a sense of the
number of participants that we have
enrolled that's on the left and on the
right the number of what I call clinical
genomes and so those are genomes that we
have on hand with matched clinical data
and as you can see the numbers for
enrolled or larger than the number of
clinical genomes this is about four or
five months out of date because we tend
to batch things except for folks that
are obviously clinically affected with a
condition that we want to analyze
genomically so we batch things and
things lag behind a little bit there but
as you heard the introduction we're
operating currently at a around seven
thousand genomes or so and you'll see
the number is how we accrue things I'm
not going to go into all the studies
shown in detail not even the ones here
but I want to briefly mention these are
kind of our three main studies they're
also the three earliest studies the
first shown in red there is what we call
our longitudinal study and the next
couple slides ago into more details
there but that's a condition that's a
study that's not bias for or against any
particular conditions and we enroll
folks about half way through pregnancy
and then follow them prospectively the
preterm birth study shown in blue is
about half cases half controls again all
trio based whole genome sequencing that
says the name implies aimed at finding
the causes the molecular causes of
preterm birth and we have finished a
cruel for that but we're very deep into
the analytics they're trying to find the
multi ohmic and clinical signatures that
help us understand and predict preterm
birth and then our smallest study
because of the type of disorder is shown
in green there and what that is is what
we call our study of congenital
disorders or congenital anomalies and so
these are conditions that are typically
manifest early in life often in the NICU
may not be obvious right away but we can
try to throw n of one analyses multiple
pipelines ask these questions at these
conditions to try to find genomic
answers there the longitudinal study
which i think is fair to say is our
flagship study and honestly what really
brought me to I TMI to inova to try to
be part of this study which I really
think is groundbreaking and exciting the
idea again is that we according to our
theme we do trio based whole genome
sequencing we generate other omics and
we take clinical data prospectively on
these patients the original goal was
5,000 now we're working towards a goal
of perhaps 10,000 trio based families
again this is a longitudinal study we
hope that folks will stay enrolled for
out their entire lives and hopefully
throughout perhaps even the lives of
their children and their children's
children these patients are enrolled
about halfway through pregnancy usually
when they enter the second trimester out
of 60 B offices all of which deliver it
our main hospital here on campus for the
hospitals or for the practices rather
our standard private care OB practices
one is a high-risk perinatal clinic
that's right here in the hospital and
then the other is what's called the
anova cares clinic which is a clinic for
the uninsured and underinsured and we
feel strongly that we want to
democratize genomics both for clinical
care and for research participation I
think one of the issues with genomics
and some of these new technologies and
this is true of other types of studies
as well is that they tend to be very
biased for people that are wealthy
enough to have the time or the means to
be able to take time off from work to
participate or or to seek out studies
and again we're trying to really make
these studies available to folks
regardless of socioeconomic status or
any other type questions like that we
collect the types of specimens that are
shown there on that fourth bullet point
and then we generate the type of omics
that I mentioned earlier and again that
are shown there and again we married us
all with clinical data I know this is a
hard slide to see exactly but this just
gives you a rough sense of the accrual
and so we're at about twenty-seven
twenty-eight hundred families now again
the size a little bit out of date but we
get between 60 and 80 new families in
the longitudinal study per month or so
and like any other study it can wax and
it can wait a little bit but we're
pretty steady there I don't want to say
to my surprise but we have a terrific
group of a clinical research associates
that are embedded in these various Toby
practices and so people including the
obstetricians the nurses that work with
them and certainly the patients have
been very eager to participate in the
study and I think that's something that
before we started this we honestly
didn't really know where people to be
interested in this with this perhaps
interrupt workflows in busy clinical
practices and so on but seems to be
working out very well excuse me one
thing I want to mention here is that
partly serendipitously but again partly
intentionally because we've tried to
emphasize this idea that we're being
democratic in terms of participation is
that we do have a very diverse
population of folks and so the map is
showing you where people in our study
were born we have genome and all
people obviously the people who were
born outside the United States came to
the United States to have their babies
so all the babies were born here in a
Commonwealth of Virginia of course a
number of the parents themselves were
born in the United States as well some
of the numbers here are overlapping but
we have especially high numbers and
folks of Central American parts of South
American origin but then people from all
over the world including Africa as you
can see Asia Europe Middle East and so
on and then on the other side there of
course is just a simple PCA plot showing
for about the first six to seven hundred
parents in our studies just and sexually
where they're from I'm not going to go
into this point in detail but of course
having a very diverse cohort is a
double-edged sword if we're trying to
understand the causes of a
multifactorial or complex condition like
preterm birth it can make things more
difficult where the ideal population
might be much more homogenous of course
we're doing n of one analyses it makes
this a very powerful tool because we can
analyze a specific variant that we find
not only based on a population overall
but that we can look at that allele
frequency based on the specific
subpopulation so for example if
someone's of Korean ancestry we can
compare the prevalence of that variant
in other folks of that or more related
aunts histories and again I'm not going
to go into this but we do a lot of work
on evolutionary genetics in this slide
and population genomics all aimed at
helping inform us being able to better
assign or more intelligently assigned
pathogenicity or deleterious pneus to an
allele that we detect I mentioned the
congenital disorder study I'm just going
to come back to that now because that's
where some of the cases are going to
come from i'm going to talk to you about
this is mostly a NICU based study we
have a pretty large NICU here on campus
usually over 100 kids in it but we also
include other than children in the NICU
other kids with congenital or genetic
disorders again some of these are
obvious at birth some of these such as
developmental delay or
immunodeficiencies might not show up
until slightly later again it's a much
smaller study because fortunately these
conditions aren't as common but we get a
few families a week on average and we
use the same methods I mentioned before
trio based whole genome sequence
other omics all married with clinical
data and another of the things I'm not
going to go into detail is you can
imagine having the amount and the
diversity of the different types of data
that we have we have to have an
incredibly robust IT infrastructure and
our leaders on the IP side Aaron black
and grey gillies have done a great deal
of work and spend a lot of sleepless
nights them and their teams making sure
that all the data are appropriately
secured then all the data types can be
used to talk to each other and can
correlate that we can allow people to
use these data sources that we're
collaborating with our parts of these
data sources but that we do so in a way
that's in accordance with our IRB and
that's carefully controlled that takes a
lot of work again as you can imagine and
it's something that really enables a
this genomic engine of ours to run so
it's that I'm going to switch gears a
fair bit now and just to go into a few
al up straight of specific case examples
run to see that some of the types of
patients we look at and then I also want
to highlight some of the ways that i use
the ingenuity pipelines which is
honestly been a lot of fun has been has
been very successful I want to put this
in context a little bit I think it's
important to point to the fact that i'm
sure a lot of the people listening to
this webinar realize it but a lot of
these Mendelian disorders that's gregor
mendel of course on that stamp where
these congela disorders are individually
rare and might have only been reported
in a couple people in the world or a few
families but in aggregates are pretty
common about 5% of why born infants have
these types of conditions and a lot of
these conditions aren't obvious right at
birth might not show up to early
adulthood and it's estimated that a
percent or perhaps even higher by age 25
have these types of conditions so again
while these are individually rearing in
aggregate they're very common in so it's
important to be able to recognize the
diagnose and therefore be able to better
treat patients with these conditions
these images and I'll go into a few of
these in detail as part of some of the
examples show some of the types of
that we've studied and so these include
conditions that affect the skeleton
different organ systems the brain and
other organ systems and that that pie
chart at the bottom is showing you
diagnosis in our longitudinal cohort
that's the cohort I talked about before
this is diagnosis at about one year of
age and so in blue those are most of the
kids who are healthy right unfortunately
don't have diseases if they're diagnosed
with the conditions such as diagnosis of
developmental delay or asthma or other
conditions we can start to build cohorts
around those and look at those
genomically to see if we can detect
answers there either on an N of 1 or
kind of a combined basis and then in
colors those are the different
conditions that would congenital that
have showed up in our population just
buy one year of age and I very in a
quick and dirty way kind of assign
different organ systems that they've
been affected but of course some of
those conditions affect multiple organ
systems and again what was perhaps
surprising to me though is that we get
the expected proportion of health sword
and disease within our lunge atul
cohorts meaning it really is a very good
control cohort and we use it as a
control in a lot of situations so we see
a lot of the rare conditions not all of
them of course to the size of the cohort
but we do see those and we see a lot of
kids who are fortunately healthy I want
to make this point so I think it's a
very important point I think a lot of us
on the call as people involved in
genomics for one way another we realize
the importance of being able to diagnose
these kids but I want to underscore that
point with some concrete data and I know
these data because I spent a lot of
sleepless nights working on this so
currently if you look pretty strictly as
of a few weeks ago there are a little
over three thousand genes known to be
involved in Mendelian disorders of
course there many more men dealing
disorders then this not the causes of
all of them haven't been discovered and
some genes might have multiple sometimes
even more than a dozen different allelic
conditions and so I went through my kind
of one by one and to think about what
could be done different would medical
care be different more tailored if we
knew the underlying molecular cause
and in almost half the time you would do
different interventions with molecular
causes I think it's actually downplays
things a lot so this wouldn't include
things or conditions where it would be
beneficial to have the underlying
molecular diagnosis where sometimes that
information might not lead to something
dramatic in terms of differences in
treatment but certainly could affect
things like medical decision making
information about prognosis certainly
providing knowledge to patients and
families so they're not going through
these endless tie-in ova diagnostic
Odysseys as the term goes these days of
course a lot of these conditions he's
been dealing conditions manifest in
childhood so it's not surprising that
most of the time almost ninety six
percent of the time the interventions
are done during childhood and I keep a
database of these which is still housed
at the National Institutes of Health
through the NHGRI I update this just
about daily and then every one to two
months a new update is pushed through to
the website so if you're interested in a
certain condition and knowing would
something being done differently if it
were if some lesser cause were known one
can go to this database and find us as
well as links to other resources such as
DB sniffs such as clinvar and then
specific clinical information about
those the other point I'd like to
emphasize here is that part a lot of
through the successes of things like
genomic sequencing and related
technologies that a tremendous wave of
discovery has happened so i looked at
the last two years for example and on
average over the last two years over 12
new disease genes per month were
discovered as being involved in human
conditions which is as you can as you
can imagine a lot of genes and it
doesn't even new allelic conditions that
have been discovered with previously
implicated genes and if you look at the
x-axis here I think what's really
impressive is that the vast majority
we're done using some sort of genomic
technique either exomes or genomes and a
lot of them were done just by using for
example you can see that first tick line
on the on the x-axis just by exomes
alone doing exomes on maybe a handful of
patients or a couple families and not
having to do long pro Maneri analyses
like linkage analysis or even homeless
homozygosity mapping or so on really
changed the game and the and the speed
at which things proceed very different
obviously than how things were a decade
ago unfortunately I think current
practices still tends to be this and I
know this is hard to see so I'll just
explain what this is this is a timeline
for a child born in our NICU who had
kind of a confusing mix of different
conditions and each box there shows a
different test that was done to try to
figure out what was going on with the
child some of these were traditional
genetic tests like karyotype and
microarray or sequencing panels some of
them are biochemical tests some of these
were radiologic studies some of these
were clinical tests like having a good
pediatric opthamologist try to look at
the child and see what's going on and so
what ends up happening is that often we
do this test after test after test this
kind of a death by a thousand cuts
approach until someone finally throws up
their hands which is okay fine we're
going to an exome or genome and we get
the answer that way I think this is
problematic for a couple reasons one is
that obviously we don't get answers to
the patients and the families as soon as
we could secondly this ends up therefore
hampering clinical care right so we
can't do more tailored as I showed you
in the previous slides more tailored
more specific care that's often
beneficial and then third this ends up
being a much more expensive way to
practice medicine right we're doing lots
of tests that are individually not as
cheap not as expensive but in aggregate
are expensive and then finally we add on
a test at the end and I noticed is
controversial but I would advocate for
doing some of these genomic testing some
of these genomic applications earlier in
the process I think we've shown some
good evidence that this is a wise way to
proceed and certainly other groups are
looking at this as well such as groups
in Toronto such as Stephen King's more
who's recently gone to San Diego that we
should applying these techniques earlier
in a lot of situations and as an example
of this this is a child as you can see
now born in our NICU this child had
pretty massive hepatosplenomegaly and so
this imaging here is showing you that
this child had a very large liver and a
very large spleen
at first it wasn't clear what this child
had it was thought that it might be some
kind of vascular and atomic anomaly that
was basically causing blood to to back
up and make these organs enlarge and we
did genomics on this child and found out
pretty quickly that the child hadn't
even picked type-c disease and I
remember very vividly I was at a shg in
California and I got a call from one of
the bioinformatics is asking you could
just being even pick and on my phone i'm
able to get the electronic healthcare
records look and I thought yeah and I
was I said yeah absolutely this kid does
this was something that was on our
differential but we didn't know for sure
and so the kid had a clinical panel that
was out at the same time that one of the
commercial labs and this gene happened
to be on it and i called up that lab
immediately and so that we'd found this
on a research basis can they please
confirm this very very quickly because
we need this information for clinical
care and so we were able to do that and
get them to rush it to get to the CLIA
validated answer very quick shown
there's our Sanger validation of it to
make sure it was real and we got that
turn over very quickly and then got the
answer to the kids so I got the college
Friday we got the Sanger turned around
in the next couple days and the kid I'll
by Monday or Tuesday in with a
biochemical geneticist in discussing
with the transplant surgeon and others
and all this was directed very
fortuitously through Denny Porter who's
one of the world experts on this
condition he's the clinical director of
NICHD it was a very rewarding thing to
know that um you know by finding this
answer we could have the world experts
on these conditions talking to each
other to make sure there's a child got
the best possible care for example he
was able to get IV cyclodextrin that was
aimed to help his liver hold over until
transplant least its head transplant and
is doing well from that so I just want
to show you kind of some of the examples
I want to emphasize that you know we use
a lot of different pipelines I think
there's all pipelines have different
pluses and minuses so I'm going to show
you some cases using the ingenuity
pipelines I will want to be clear though
that some of these were found through
other pipelines first but i want to show
you how easy it is to use the ingenuity
pipeline and i put some these cases into
their pipelines of show
of how easy is it see how easy it is to
use and again as a way of disclosure I'm
a medical geneticist I'm not a violent
for Madison so I kind of dabble a little
bit I would not call myself an expert
but for someone like me this works
amazingly well unless we solve cases
really quickly it lets me when cases I
haven't solved kind of noodle around
with them and try to look at new
candidate genes or new jeans has just
been published and it's been
tremendously helpful so in this
particular case this case of new and
pick type C I uploaded the data and that
took about about a minute i plug in a
few quick things like said this is a
genetic disease not cancer and you know
just to kind of do the standard analysis
and then I press run and I was sitting
there using through a structured
connection on my laptop at home my wife
was next to me watching I think NCIS or
something i get i got up to get a drink
of orange juice i SAT back down i
already had the email saying that your
analysis is ready and this is the little
email and i got that about a minute
after i submitted it and then as you can
see from this i just went in and took
another you know 30 seconds to load and
I immediately had from this true based
whole genome sequencing data I
immediately had a single answer which I
know is correct because we did a idea
that kind of a true positive case this
is just breathtaking to me I know I come
across as doing an ad for ingenuity now
but it's really a powerful tool is one
of the bound format assists I work with
said you know it's just not fair that
you know we have these tools that enable
us to to provide answers so quickly it's
really a really tremendously rewarding
and again I love the fact that I as a
pediatric geneticist as a clinician that
I can go into these titties and use
these tools and shirt and do things with
a clinical mind I don't have to wait
necessarily for the bioinformatics asst
to do some of the analyses that they do
so obviously those can be very important
and powerful as well this is another
case this is as you want to read more
about this here's the citation there so
this was a child that was again born in
our Nicky woodbourne a little bit early
was iugr which means the child was
smaller had interview
in growth restriction when the mom was
pregnant and then has its vague cluster
of kind of confusing medical conditions
so this is a 3d reconstruction of the
skull the skull shape is a little
different than usual the profile you can
see the forehead is a little kind of
what's called frontal bossing so a
little more promise than usual and in
the bottom of you looking at the back of
the skull and what we're seeing there is
that we're seeing the sagittal suture
that suture going down the bottom is
connected and it should be and so they
had to have surgery to separate that and
the child also has this kind of you know
wasn't growing terrifically seem to have
some renal some kidney differences maybe
some endocrine differences but not
really clear at all what was going on
and as a lot of these kids do he had a
pretty extensive work up and a bunch of
different tests both molecular tests
biochemical tests that didn't show the
answer so we did a whole genome on the
folks shown here so the kid shown at the
bottom and then also the that's the
child and also the other members of the
family and everybody else in the family
was healthy didn't seem to have any
signs of disease or you know really
anything similar all to the child so we
did whole genome sequencing we found a
mutation in this child we found that
same mutation in these other folks these
other folks were unaffected and by
instituting a specific imprinting type
pipeline we're able to figure out that
this mutation was the cause and
otherwise it would have been overlooked
and so you only get this condition if
you have a mutation and if you get the
mutation from the mother right because
if you get the mutation from the dad the
gene is and this is a bad way to put it
but not active or kind of turned off and
was interesting is when we went back and
told the family about this you know the
depths the grandfather there at the top
said oh yeah I had this distant relative
and I never thought about this but she
has the same thing he or she rather had
the same thing it reminded me of what my
grandson had and the inheritance was
such even though week that person has
long since passed away that it could
have been the same condition and I've
since had conversations with the other
members of this family for family
planning things like preimplantation
genetic denotes diagnosis now that they
know they carry this mutation I think
the other thing that was critically
dramatic about this is that when we
figure this out you only about ten or
twelve other folks in the world
have this condition and all the other
folks in the world had pretty Frank and
pretty severe adrenal hyperplasia so
under development of the adrenal glands
and so in these other kids it was severe
enough that the kids were getting
adrenal replacement this child Lee
figured out my bound format assists one
of my bad for asus told me that we had
this figured out and I realized I'm
looking at the medical record that this
child was about to go into surgery and
so knowing that he was at high risk of
an adrenal crisis we were able to
quickly get on the phone talk to the
anesthesiologist talk to the surgeons
and the other folks taken care of him to
make sure that they did a very simple
thing just gave him stretch dose
steroids prior to surgery because his
adrenal glands don't make the steroids
that they're supposed to and so I don't
know if this is a life-saving thing but
it certainly could have been you know
certainly very dramatic and eye-opening
experience to me about the power of some
of these methods and some of these
analyses so another case this was a
child again these are outfits were in
NICU this is neuroimaging these area
arrows are showing you that this child
had these kind of like stroke-like
episodes during infancy also had severe
dermatological can dish ins a lot of
skin missing on the scalp but not clear
what was going on um these are at the
bottom there this in this figure either
this is our patient and then some other
patients shown above this child did not
have severe limb hypoplasia she had
maybe kind of hypoplastic toenails um
she had scalps lesions like some of
these folks had that are shown there but
we found this and then in collaboration
with a group at University of British
Columbia led by milan patel and then our
collaborators at institutes for systems
biology led by Jared Roche and Gustavo
glutes and their team they had four
other families with mutations in the
same gene and so this is a brand new
cause of disease now the the fifth cause
of what's called Adams all her syndrome
and it's amazing I guess the emphasis is
amazing how quickly we can go from
answers to the new answer for a genetic
condition a new published answer and
actually since this was published our
other collaborators who continue to work
on this condition have found a six gene
so now there's six genes X and explain
Adams all
again a really fast moving field here
and these are some of the collaborators
I like I think this is funny I think
only geneticists would be amused by this
but this is from their press release
about this this is a dominant condition
we think it's very funny that this is
showing you consanguinity or receptive
conditions but they are terrific janome
assist that's Jared Roach and Gustavo
gruesome and certainly some of the
leaders in this field so just another
case this is a child you can see from
the arrows born with vertebral anomalies
have to get surgery and born with a
single kidney otherwise doing pretty
well and this is the child when she came
in and saw us and again the really
amazing thing to me was that this was a
de novo mutation in EP three hundred and
some of you guys might know EP 300
mutations are supposed to give you
rubenstein kv syndrome which isn't
supposed to have birth defects which has
a characteristic facial appearance and
it's almost pathognomonic appearance to
the sums and the big toes this child I
would argue doesn't have those I think
it's an example again of how using
genomics on a broader much more
hypothesis freeway is allowing us to
rewrite the textbooks about what happens
what manifests from mutations and a lot
of times this is a very humbling thing
because what we thought we knew that was
caused by mutations in certain genes is
just it's just not true at all we're
really stretching the phenotypes that
we're getting and I think our view of
this will be very different 10 years
from now when many more people are
sequenced than they are now another
example of this this was a child with
Epstein's anomaly and that figure
showing you this is anomaly affecting
one of the valves of the heart the child
had Epstein's anomaly as did the dad the
child had also had other cardiac
anomalies and there aren't really
published genes that give you kind of
isolated Ebstein's anomaly there are
that give us teens anomaly with other
things but but not but not that but
again I wanted to show the the power of
the hydrogen pipeline here so this is
just some screenshots from using the
pipeline it's incredibly user-friendly
and I feel like I'm good as a few things
i'll admit that one of the things I'm
not good at is computer programming and
and you know I'm not the most tech savvy
person have to admit but even for me
this is this works tremendously well we
just input we just kind of pulled over
drops and dragged the genomic files from
there and that's what that screenshots
just showing you and then I just typed
in one clinical thing I just typed in
Epstein's anomaly and put it in there
and again I hit analyze got up for you
know 30 seconds or so to get a snack SAT
back down and I had the right answer
which is a mutation in my h7 in this
case that both the child and the dad had
again I think this is it's not that
dramatic because we know that my 87
mutations can cause Epstein's anomaly
but as far as I could tell it was to the
literature when I saw this child before
we have the answer pretty quickly
ebstein's anomaly all is also supposed
to go I mean sorry my seven mutations
are also social along with other cardiac
finding like ventricular non compaction
not just isolated Epstein's anomaly like
the child head so again we're really
stretching the phenotypic range that we
get from a lot of these conditions and
this is from the consult note and this
is the original console note saying you
know it just doesn't make sense then why
87 couldn't be involved and of course we
found in my 87 mutation in this kid I
often when I present this case I kind of
joke around about who the dopey
consultant was and it was me you know
and again so the eye open experience and
that's my boss by the way behind me John
neither Huber the ex-head of NCI looking
skeptically as at me as I try to explain
something that's often how he looks at
me alright so I hope these cases have
been helpful to illustrate some of the
types of patients we have as well as
about the type of data sets that we use
to derive it and again I really enjoy
using the ingenuity variant tools to
look at this and they've been
tremendously powerful as as you can see
I continue to look at a lot of cases
this way including some cases honestly I
don't think are going to be that easy to
solve on an end of one basis for example
we have over a dozen kids with
gastroschisis which is a congenital
anomaly affecting the abdominal wall I
don't think we're going to have a kind
of an obvious easy Medellin answer but
this allows us to aggregate these cases
and look for common patterns using these
tools I haven't found anything obvious
yet so we're still we still have a I
some leads on gastroschisis but again
using these tools is is really fun and
when there's a new gene published or
some new insight we can go back and
reanalyze and and see if we get new
answers that way so again if you'll
indulge me I'm going to just try to
communicate some lessons learned and the
first and hopefully this has come across
pretty clearly already is this idea that
the diagnostic paradigm has shifted and
so it used to be kind of in this
diagnostic paradigm this is a show how
some of you guys might recognize I
believe this is still in reruns though
perhaps there isn't in the primary
production anymore what kind of the
house modality of testing right is that
someone would come in with a confusing
type of condition or something we really
don't know what the cause of it was and
we throw we do one test and that would
be wrong and we scratch our heads and do
another test and that would be wrong and
we scratch our heads and I'll have all
sorts of looking in databases and text
books and calling our friends and in the
case of house perhaps going and having
an affair or something and finally we
get an answer and things have changed
and this is to me as a physician this is
very humbling where it's no longer us
necessarily as a physician selecting the
test but rather generating a lot of
omics and clinical data and my role now
is rather to help sort or help kind of
clinically think about these data rather
than ordering this isolated test or that
isolated test and I think this is a you
know it's a tough pill to swallow for a
lot of physicians a lot of folks who are
used to being kind of the sole
proprietor of the answers the other
thing i want to emphasize and i know
we're on a webinar now so I can't ask
folks kind of for a show of hands but
there's a sense about where we are on
this this curve of genomic or precision
medicine or personalized medicine and I
know different people have different
views about this and I won't pick on
anybody else where they are but I do
think that's important to manage
perceptions is that we're very early in
the game and
so would i like to say and some of the
folks i work with like to say we're at
the Wright brothers stage of this or
perhaps Dorothea you know the Model T
stage of this is that we're very early
in the game we have a great deal to
learn about how in a single variant
affects a person's health especially
variants that are outside the
traditional XO more the exons I think we
have even more work to do tremendous
work to do to understand how these
variants affect health not only alone
but in concert with each other and in
combination with other non-genetic
factors and again how these help explain
and help predict health we have a lot of
work to do I don't say that just as kind
of a as lobbying towards job security
but I think it's important that to the
public that we don't overemphasize the
ability of personalized or precision
medicine to provide answers but that we
that we describe things carefully and
conservatively the other thing along
these lines is that we really do need to
provide helping guidance that's just
that picture is just a picture of a you
know biochemical type pathways obviously
genomics has a lot to do with that and
is very complex and that we know that
clinicians nurses doctors pharmacists
others are already incredibly taxed and
have a lot of work to do with the way
that the clinical system is set up you
know they're they're constantly being
asked to see more patients and in less
time and I think again the onus is on us
if you allow me to be up on the soapbox
to provide tools for these folks to
provide guidance for these folks so that
we're really working with them and that
we're making their life better and
easier by delivering this genomic
information not more complex not more
challenging not harder so that we're
providing more answers rather than more
questions and difficulties our research
institute works very hard in that realm
and we have a kind of a living
laboratory in that way in terms of
working alongside a lot of the
clinicians and it's again it's been a
very uh I and mind opening experience
seeing what can help them what doesn't
help them and what still needs a lot of
work for example what one of the things
that we do that I'm proud of it's very
simple it's not nearly as complex
there's a lot of things but we simply
have a very easy
line so that if folks want to get in
touch with us without any question about
genetics or genomics or what tube do I
put this in or how do I make sense of
this variant of uncertain significance
we have just a simple chat so that folks
can input information it comes to either
my phone immediately or file online it
comes to the my computer desktop it's
also linked to the phones and desktops
of a couple of my genetic counselors are
bound format assist one of my postdocs
as well so we can try to get answers for
these folks and with that I think the
most important line or the most
important lesson rather is that it
really is an amazingly fun time to be a
geneticist or perhaps we should call
ourselves into no misis you know to be
able to generate the types of data sets
to have these types of tools at our at
our fingertips is really quite wonderful
quite astounding I don't think any of us
would have guessed that we'd be able to
do what we can do you know 10 or 15
years ago I think 10 or 15 years from
now things again will be tremendously
difficult I mean sorry we will be
tremendously difficult but will also be
tremendously rewarding I think we have a
ways to go but we certainly have a lot
of material a lot of tools to get there
I'm certainly excited about that I'd
like to thank you guys very much for
your time and your patience and
hopefully your interest I'd like to
acknowledge all the folks listed here
for the sake of time I'm not going to go
through any any particular names except
for the heads of the anova translational
medicine to tutor I TMI John Muir huber
again the former director of NCI Joe
Buckley who's our current chief
scientific officer and our chief
operations officer who also previously
many of you guys may know who ran the
Cancer Genome Atlas Project out of NIH
and NCI and again I'd really like to
thank kaijin ingenuity for the
opportunity to present I'm going to end
now and I'm happy to answer any
questions at this point or take
questions offline if folks want to
contact the administrators thanks very
much thank you dr. Solomon for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A so if you have a question you'd like
to ask dr. Solomon please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on the screen and click on the
send button or answer as many of
questions that we have time for so let's
get started our first question is how is
the genomic work you you fund it thanks
yes I think this is a great question and
I and I often put this in here to make
sure that this comes up and i think this
partly speaks about why i'm talking to
you guys now so our work is all
internally funded meaning our health
care system believes very strongly in
the future of genomics and personalized
in precision medicine so they brought
John eater who were here to start this
Institute and to invest very heavily in
genomic obviously the good side of that
is that we have healthy funding the
downside of that perhaps one might say
is that we're not required such as an
NIH funded study to put things in the
public domain however we feel it's our
responsibility as researchers bioethical
e to help others find answers and part
of what we've done is cause collaborated
with ingenuity and kaijin to try to make
these data available for things for
example to be used as a control database
so that folks get access to that we feel
that's the best way that we can secure
the data keep it safe and protected in
the way that our IRB requires and the
folks who participate in our study the
way they consented to it but also again
helps fulfill our ethical responsibility
to be part of the larger genomic
community the next person says I believe
you just answered my question but I'll
ask anyhow your lab still uses sanguine
Sanger sequencing methods to verify XOM
data yeah so it's a very great question
so let me answer this in a couple
different ways or at a couple different
angles so first we do genomes not exomes
I don't think we've generated many
exomes at all maybe a few just for kind
of quality control purposes but Saul
genomes so yeah so what we do is we
still do orthogonal validation of
findings before we return them to
patients and I know there's a lot of
discussion at this point about
statistically showing that next
generation sequencing data especially if
I have a certain depth then their
questions about the need for orthogonal
sequencing so right now we try to be
very careful and when we're returning
things to patients we do still do Sanger
sequencing from the original research
samples and then we all typically also
require a separate sample to do
Clea validation remember that the stuff
that I talk to you guys about is all
done on our research basis so we are
still doing Sanger or the equivalent
validation some other type of validation
on top of on top of this I do reckon I
think it's a great question because I
think this is a fast-moving field and
for example I'm sure you guys have heard
talks and seeing data were for example
the Sanger data is actually less
trustworthy than the original
next-generation sequencing data but I
think that we and others are in many
ways trying to move a little bit
cautiously and conservatively until more
evidence comes out there but it's a as
you guys all know it's a very
fast-moving feel it's a great question
why did you choose to do whole genome
sequencing instead of two [ __ ] sequencing
yeah so another another good and
important question I think this raises a
number of points so I think a lot of us
believe that that things are moving
towards whole genome rather than whole
exome and kind of when that turnover
happens i think is none of us are
exactly clear about but the idea is that
we wanted to generate a data set that
would be useful for hopefully a lot of
time to come genome was the way to go
obviously there's downsides to that
including the expense and the turnaround
time and things like that but we wanted
to generate a data set that was
applicable hopefully for the longer term
as well as you know we're very
interested I talked a lot about
Mendelian diseases and we know that a
lot but showing out all of the answers
are in the exome for these Mendelian
diseases but a lot of the work that we
do is of course related to complex
diseases things like preterm births and
things like conditions that we don't
expect necessary to have a kind of be
due to a single hit from one mutation in
exon so having the genome enables us to
look of course outside the exons and
then the other thing along those lines
is that we do generate for example a
fair bit of RNA based and epigenetic
data so hopefully it will enable us to
correlate some of those nanak sonic
variants with some of those data sets as
well in the legend in the longitudinal
study how frequently do you follow up
with the participants and what level of
response rates have you seen yeah so we
again a good and important question so
we collect information from our
electronic healthcare record on these
folks the other thing that we do is that
every six months we have web-based
surveys that go out to them mostly they
answer them through the web through
email but they can also answer them
through a traditional mail or through
the phone and we actually have a
tremendous rate of return well over
eighty percent in some cases over ninety
percent of return on those on those data
and I think that speaks to having a
dedicated very good clinical team
primarily clinical nurses whose main job
is it to make sure that we have folks in
our studies that are continuing to
answer questionnaires and canoeing to be
invested you know we try to be careful
we try not to be pushy and do things
that we certainly never does do anything
that the IRB or the consent forms don't
allow but I think the other point that
it speaks to that is that folks are
certainly very eager for these genomics
and are in for research participation it
doesn't cost them anything to do this
other than time I think they're very
eager and and kind of like being part of
this big study your presentation has
focused on individual patient cases as
your group or have other groups done any
larger analyses using the data set yeah
so another good question so we recently
published for example on genetics and
medicine kind of a smallest by think
nice analysis where we looked at 163
genes corresponding to all the
conditions that are screened for in the
United States in newborn screening
programs in the blood based newborn
screening program or are being planned
to being initiated in the United States
or if I now actually have been initiated
in a lot of cases such as some of the
types of immuno deficiency that have
been added and so we've done these ones
like that that are I guess one could
call these um combined and of one
analyses rights are we looking at gene
tests there and we're doing similar
analyses of combined data sets like that
looking at other groups that are
penological to look at once having to do
with immunodeficiencies one time to do
with hearing loss on Dale boudin
whatever by Francis also published an
analysis looking at jeans from the
cosmic gene census and so on and then
we're very busy and again I didn't know
I know I didn't really get to that in
any of the slides but we're very busy
looking at larger analyses especially if
things like
term birth where we have some of these
cohorts and then smaller ones to we're
just kind of naturally we've hadded
groups of patients with things like
gastroschisis i mentioned as an example
we have a dozen cases and as a data set
matures meaning as the kids in the study
get older we expect to see more of these
conditions that don't pop up early in
life so we're now starting to get
diagnosis of kids with developmental
delay things like asthma things like
autism frequent infections and so we can
kind of build these cohorts out of these
as we're starting to see some of these
diagnoses being made I would like to
once again thank dr. Solomon for his
presentation do you have any final
comments no I'd like to again I just
like to thank everybody for their time
i'd like to welcome folks to to contact
me if they have questions about the data
set at all and again I think I'd like
just like to leave on a very positive
note that this is a really just terrific
field to being I think it will continue
to be even more terrific as datasets
grow and as collaborations grown as more
data are available thank you thank you
again dr. Solomon I would also like to
thank our sponsor cryogen for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing from a 12 2016
you'll receive an email from lab roots
let me know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we helped you again soon bye